il n'y a pas de mots c'est catastrophe
c'est
une catastrophe qui s'est abattue sur
vous avec le comportement de votre fils
de tous les côtés
d'être avec nous vous êtes l'avocat de
Bouchaïb alors l'Amérique canne donc
après cette décision vous avez perdu
votre place au marché depuis combien de
temps vous aviez cette place au marché
vous allez donner votre avis aussi et
vous aussi chez vous est-ce que vous
trouvez ça normal ou pas alors vous
aviez vous l'avez depuis combien de
temps cette place je commence à faire
les tirages au sort pour avoir cette
place depuis 2001 depuis 2001 d'accord
fin 2002 j'ai eu l'octrode 7 places et
je travaille toujours sur ce marché j'ai
jamais eu de problème
ni mes enfants ils ont jamais fait de
problème jusqu'à cette catastrophe déjà
je suis pas là pour défendre mon fils
mon fils il a fait
ce qui est pas excusable il a ce qu'il a
fait il est atroce je viens pas je viens
pas défendre mon fils la seule victime
dans ce problème c'est Madame Angèle
dieu merci qu'il est bien maintenant
alors ça c'est mon fils il est entre la
main de la justice il est dans un centre
fermé la justice il est en train de
faire son travail avec moi fils et il a
eu ce qu'il mérite alors ça c'est un
sujet le deuxième sujet c'est de ma
place
moi je me bats pour avoir un travail
déjà j'ai créé une petite agence de
voyage en 2016 et après pile-poil on
tombe dans le covid et après c'est que
des loyers à payer des et j'arrivais
plus je l'ai arrêté en mars dernier et
maintenant je vais voir autre chose mais
ce samedi c'est le seul jour de travail
que j'avais vous demandez à tous les
forains à tous les commerçants le samedi
le samedi je vends le bazar je vois les
trucs à 1,50 € les éponges des trucs des
piles et j'ai ma clientèle j'ai ma place
j'ai mon travail et il me reste que ça
mais après maintenant je me suis inscrit
pour faire une autre formation pour
remplir les autres jours parce que quand
j'avais l'argent je pouvais pas
travailler lundi mardi mercredi sur les
marchés et j'ai pas de chance je me bats
avec je travaille avec ma transpiration
je me bats j'ai des enfants qu'est-ce
que je fais maintenant je perds même la
petite la semaine ce que je gagne dans
cette place ça m'aide alors pourquoi
m'écrit elle est avec l'avocat de la
ville de Cannes on peut intervenir en
direct quand on veut voilà pour vous
répondre donc voilà je vous le dirai à
un moment et oui elle me dit que vous
n'avez cette place qu'une demi-journée
par semaine qu'une demi-journée par
semaine parce que avant j'avais lundi un
marché mardi à marcher et après quand
j'ai fait cette agence pour m'éloigner
de marché pour même manip de froid du
vent et ben ça a pas marché
malheureusement ça a pas marché on est
tombé dans le covid il y a pas de voyage
je gagne rien et il me restait cette
place pourquoi on l'enlève qu'est-ce que
j'ai fait est-ce que moi j'ai commis
quelque chose et pourquoi on l'enlève
sans justice
ceux qui comprennent la décision de
l'Américaine Géraldine toi tu comprends
pourquoi
les larmes aux yeux parce que je vous
trouve plein de d'empathie plein de
compréhension vous êtes absolument pas
belliqueux et je comprends que ce soit
pour vous un cataclysme et ne double
peine je comprends mais de l'autre côté
en fait pour moi le maire de Cannes il
veut protéger ses administrés et par
cette décision il montre son il montre
l'ordre il montre le fait que voilà vous
pouvez être victime aussi vous de gens
qui vont venir vous parler la vengeance
l'ordre de troubles à l'ordre public et
donc je comprends et aujourd'hui face à
un sentiment de laxisme face à un
sentiment d'impunité bah peut-être qu'il
faut essayer autre chose et vous êtes
donc la victime de cette autre chose
c'est-à-dire qu'il va falloir peut-être
déloger les gens dans qui ont qui ont
des aides dans des dans des dans des HLM
tel qu'il va falloir couper les aides
sociales parce que en fait il y a plein
de systèmes ça ne marche plus il y a
plein de trucs
du laxisme de la vie et je pense qu'il y
a un moment donné je sais que c'est une
double peine mais je voilà je comprends
que le maire de Cannes ait pris cette
décision
mais ce n'est pas victime je suis désolé
de vous le dire mais je pense que le
maire de Cannes a fait ce qu'on
attendait depuis très longtemps de
Monsieur un exemple monsieur n'est pas
victime monsieur est coupable quand on a
un enfant qui a 14 ans qui est dans la
rue
tu sais quoi tous les enfants de 14 ans
ne fera pas des vieilles dames pour les
tuer quand on a un enfant de 14 ans
monsieur est responsable un enfant ça
s'éduque c'est un monsieur d'éduquer on
rappelle qu'il a pas 16 17 18 ans 14 ans
depuis le début on dit que les enfants
de moins de 16 ans les parents doivent
être responsables enfin le maire de
Cannes agit et bien c'est monsieur qui
est responsable et tous les enfants que
tous les parents qui les enfants de 14
ans qui sont des délinquants parlent pas
délinquance cet enfant a failli tuer une
dame et bien qu'ils vont commettre des
crimes ce seront aux parents il a
désormais de dans des cours avec la
justice je suis désolé monsieur vous
êtes responsable de votre fils non mais
attendez bouchaïbes qu'est-ce que vous
dites est-ce que vous entendez
excusez-moi excusez-moi en fait il faut
distinguer parce que depuis deux jours
on entend à peu près tout sur les
réseaux sociaux et dans les médias il
faut distinguer des responsabilités il y
a une question d'une responsabilité
pénale et la question la responsabilité
civile sur la question la responsabilité
civile les parents sont responsables du
fait de leurs enfants et c'est le cas
depuis le Code civil de 1804 de Napoléon
donc il y a pas de difficulté là-dessus
et Monsieur et Monsieur Bouchaïb dans
l'éventualité de dommage et intérêt il
va devoir assumer comme tous parents
assume pour les bêtises de ses enfants
donc sur ça il y a pas on n'est pas dans
une situation d'impunité c'est quasiment
il y a pas de difficulté là-dessus mais
ce que je suis en train de vous
expliquer c'est que on n'est pas dans
une situation d'impunité bien au
contraire monsieur monsieur Bouchaïb il
va devoir assumer par rapport au
comportement de son fils nous ce que
l'on dénonce c'est le comportement
disproportionné et la mesure
disproportionnée qui qui veut qu'on ne
retire à ce monsieur le droit de
travailler mais excusez-moi de le dire
c'est le monde à l'envers on peut pas
d'un côté venir demander à la
responsabilité des parents et retirer le
travail qui permet à se perdre de payer
je veux dire faut qu'on soit un peu
raisonnable d'accord je suis le seul
responsable envie d'anticiper la mairie
ils ont pas de responsabilité moi à mes
enfants ils ont pas une j'ai pas la
chance d'avoir une villa et mon fils
attendez monsieur que je finis de parler
je n'étais pas couper merci alors j'ai
pas une villa haut de Cannes et mon fils
quand il sort il trouve le goudron et
les voitures moi je lui dis qu'à la
maison mais il y a 160 éducateurs dans
la rue alors nous si on est délaissé et
c'est au responsable de prendre le
responsabilités alors moi je fais tout
ce que je peux avec mon fils parce que
je vais pas rester avec lui 24 heures
sur 24 je vais au travail je travaille
et votre enfant non non je dis pas ça
j'ai dit que je suis responsable vous
avez dit non j'ai pas dit je suis
responsable de mon fils parce qu'il est
minable monsieur je l'ai dit je le redis
et j'ai dit que mon enfant tant que je
tant que tout je fais ce que je peux je
fais même plus que ce que je peux mon
fils il a jamais rien fait il a fait ce
crime qui est qui est pas bien et il est
en train de payer moi qu'est-ce que j'ai
fait moi et mes enfants que hier ils ont
été
cinq enfants et il vous dira maître
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont eu hier soir parce
que parce que le maire il a divulgué mon
nom ici on a pas dit mon nom de famille
comme je vous ai dit la dernière fois
Cyril quand il y a des filles dans des
classes et des filles dans des amphis
qui porte le même nom on va pas sortir
sans même là la justice il sort pas son
nom il sort pas sinon hier quand il a
dit Monsieur le Maire ce qui s'est passé
c'est que hier après-midi la mairie de
Cannes a sorti ce communiqué de presse
sur lequel on va revenir tout à l'heure
on a la décence dans les médias ou dans
la justice on l'a dit tout à l'heure de
ne pas de ne pas de ne pas révéler le
nom de ce monsieur
pour une raison très simple c'est
qu'évidemment directement après que ce
communiqué de la mairie soit publié
toute la sphère de l'extrême droite qui
est très active sur les réseaux sociaux
je vais pas vous la prendre et parti
chercher sur les réseaux sociaux la page
Facebook du père et on a des tweets où
on a la photo du père avec l'enfant où
on a des termes injurieux que je me
permets pas que je me permets pas de
lire dans lesquels dans lesquels on les
a on appelle à l'état Basset ou à les
pendre sur la place publique directement
directement en réponse au communiqué de
la mairie de CAD et moi j'ai post une
question est-ce que ça on le cautionne
pas du tout
alors on va on va revenir sur le
communiqué de la ville de Cannes qui a
réagi à la décision donc Bouchaïb avait
un emplacement à la mairie de Cannes
depuis plus de 20 ans la Mira décidé de
suspendre son emplacement au marché il
dénonce la médiatisation de la faire par
Bouchaïb rappelle que la seule victime
dans ce dossier c'est la retraité
agressée par le fils de bouchaïbes que
ce même fils est connu localement pour
avoir été expulsé de collège pour avoir
insulté un adulte et blesser un autre
élève avec un objet danger que la
famille de Bouchaïb doit être une somme
importante à la CAF à cause de sommes
indument versées selon certaines sources
bouchées devraient 61000 euros à la
casse lui affirme que c'est 59000
ils affirment aussi qu'il ne s'agit que
d'une seule qu'une seule de mes journées
par semaine il rappelle que les parents
doivent être responsables de leurs
enfants c'est ça Gilles oui alors il y a
déjà des faits qui sont de la part de la
mairie assez accusatoire contre votre
fils qui donc a été viré plusieurs fois
d'établissement scolaire notamment une
fois pour avoir mal parlé à un CPE et
ils font état en 2019 je cite d'une
information préoccupante concernant
votre fils quel est cette information
préoccupante moi je suis même pas au
courant de ça hein c'est ça le problème
attendez
je suis pas au courant de ce qu'il a dit
Monsieur le Maire
et si il a dit ça à mon fils c'est qu'il
vit dans une cité moi Dieu seul sait
qu'est-ce qu'on entend dans les cités
ils sont livrés à eux-mêmes ses enfants
il faut que l'amirer aussi il prend sa
responsabilité faut la mairie c'est pas
que nous seul
s'il vous plaît attendez monsieur et là
Monsieur le Maire il a que ça à faire à
aller à la casse chercher qu'est-ce que
c'est normal
Monsieur le Maire là vous me condamnez
comme moi non au moins le travailleur
non il faut mais vous n'avez pas répondu
monsieur ça veut dire que votre fils
était déjà connu pour plusieurs faits
mal parlé un CPE j'irai plusieurs
collèges
dans notre entourage peut-être un élève
turbulent qui a pu être pas au courant
on a posé une question sur une
information préoccupante moi je voudrais
préciser que les informations
préoccupantes la famille elle est pas au
courant de ces informations
préoccupantes
directement à l'administration qui
transmet si nécessaire aux autorités
compétentes mais les parents c'est le
principe c'est comme ça que ça marche
c'est comme ça que ça marche mais moi ce
que je voudrais ce que je voudrais te
dire ok c'est que l'ensemble 14 ans est
viré pour violence vous n'êtes pas
convoqué vous n'êtes pas au courant la
mairie de pas le père il faut distinguer
l'exclusion de l'information
préoccupante
la formation préoccupante le père
n'était pas au courant l'exclusion bien
sûr que le périph et c'est là que le
problème il y a pas de difficulté
simplement parce que je dois dire c'est
que lorsque le 9 septembre 2022 le maire
de Cannes décide de retirer cet
emplacement vous n'avez rien des motifs
qui vient qui sont invoqués aujourd'hui
dans le communiqué de presse
c'est-à-dire que dans le dans la
décision du 9 septembre 2022 dont on
dont on est prêt on est prêt à
communiquer vous n'avez que il y a un
risque de trouble à l'ordre public on
préfère vous retirer votre emplacement
c'est tout vous n'avez pas ces
explications sur la CAF et puis bon
permettez-moi de poser la question
comment il a eu ces informations la cave
ça dépend du département ça dépend pas
de l'Américaine
extrêmement sensible d'enquêter pour
justifier leur décision
que finalement la mairie a trop d'info
qu'elle devrait pas avoir bon c'est pas
ça
aujourd'hui donc on vous a retiré votre
emplacement
vous êtes
vous pouvez vous avez aucun aucun revenu
vous devez 59000 euros à la CAF non je
dois pas moi je considère que je dois
rien à la CAF parce que
c'est moi parler sinon on part et on
vous laisse parler alors quand il pose
une question il faut que je finis après
alors la carte c'est une une affaire au
tribunal moi j'ai attaqué j'ai constaté
j'ai contesté ça parce que c'est des
calculs il y a rien il y a rien qui a
été alors et comme Monsieur le Maire il
a autre chose à faire il a pas et qui
sait qu'il y a non non qu'est-ce qu'il y
a dans cette information donc là c'est
est-ce qu'il a été chercher pour l'avoir
où ils ont où ils l'ont donné ça c'est
le secret c'est le secret alors et
combien de citoyens c'est le maire il a
il a c'est c'est secret de de la CAF
pour le sortir et donner le nom et faire
peur à toute une famille et donner le
nom et le prénom il sait que la justice
est le protège il peut même même le
tribunal il est passé à Wiko pour qu'on
protège ses enfants on veut les mettre
sur le droit chemin on va c'est ils sont
dans un centre d'éducation fermé
éducation fermée on va pas de on va pas
les mettre dans dans un moulin je les
défends pas ils ont fait un truc atroce
je les défends pas et ils ont eu ce
qu'il mérite maintenant c'est un autre
sujet c'est plus le sujet ce sujet pour
moi il est clos ils ont pris et ils vont
prendre ce qu'il mérite maintenant on
parle de l'autre sujet moi et mes filles
et mes enfants qu'est-ce qu'on a fait
pour que notre nom il soit divulgué à
tout le monde et qu'on vient nous
menacer mes fils peur rire tout le monde
est venu au salon il avait peur on a
appelé le 17 est-ce que Monsieur le
Maire il pouvait pas m'appeler et il me
dit Monsieur qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
et il me met alors et ben faites
attention à votre environnement de suite
la place il faut qu'il saute et on va le
sortir de l'appartement où j'écris à
Monsieur Darmanin pour le sortir et
qu'est-ce que je vais donner pour vous
monsieur que votre fille et votre fils a
été quasiment tous une vieille dame
c'est mérité juste un avertissement au
téléphone
avec mes enfants c'est ce que vous
voulez vous aussi ben je dis que
Monsieur Tout ce que dites-moi ça et moi
vous voulez que je devienne SDF moi et
ma famille mais je dis moi je connais
des mères des grands-mères
c'est le problème
mon fils qui a fait le crime et il a eu
ce qu'il mérite maintenant c'est un
autre sujet arrêtez non il y a pas
d'autres sujets non non non il y a un
autre sujet
un problème éducatif il y a les mères
moi que je connais des mères que j'ai
entendu je vois des émissions des mères
ils prennent les SDF et les mettre dans
des centres et il leur donne du travail
maintenant le Maire nos lumières de
Cannes il veut faire le contraire
il y aura un avant et un après il veut
montrer aux autres c'est-à-dire que vous
vous êtes le cobaye peut-être de montrer
aux autres que si vous éduquez pas vos
enfants si vous faites pas la fête de la
politique si vous il fait de la
diabétique
si vous faites pas ce qu'il faut pour
vos enfants voilà ce que vous risquez
voilà ce que vous risquez pas sauf qu'il
faut pour mes enfants
il est dans la rue
il a fait une grande connerie et il y a
la justice
en France il fait son travail Monsieur
le Maire il est pas juge il a pas à mon
neveu mais quand il y a des signaux et
tout ça il veut montrer aux parents
faites gaffe parce que
on a fait le nécessaire mais on peut pas
rester derrière un gosse
de famille monsieur vous pouvez pas
rester avec vous le respect vous avez
des enfants
il faut vous pouvez pas suivre votre
enfant 24 heures sur 24 je vais pas
mettre dans les documents pour les gens
comment font les emmerder
problème
à ce jeu là où les enfants qui passent
leur premier un peu enfant on va avoir
leur famille expulsée
cette famille combien on va expliquer
cette famille quand on va expliquer tout
le monde et les autres qui vont payer
pour les c'est à dire c'est un membre de
votre famille quelque chose on va voir
vous êtes d'accord pour c'est la mesure
a été prise en d'autres mairies et ça
marche plutôt parce que c'est visuasif
et il y a pas de
[Musique]
sur lequel vous n'avez pas été très
clair si je puis me permettre c'est
l'histoire de la moi c'est l'histoire de
la CAF on vous accuse de mentir d'être
des arnaqueurs à la CAF et ça c'est très
rapide laissez-moi juste préciser
mais parce que le maire
mes informations j'ai eu des gens de
votre famille aujourd'hui vous le savez
il s'agit d'un prêt qui a été contracté
et qui n'a pas été déclaré au fisc et
qu'on vous reproche aujourd'hui est-ce
que c'est ça qu'on vous reproche
pourquoi vous ne parlez pas de ça je
parle de ça alors je vous écoute juste
laissé monsieur monsieur qu'il me coupe
pas parce que chaque fois il dès que je
parle beaucoup
je veux pas dire tout là je veux pas il
y a un truc au tribunal nous on a
attaqué c'est pas la CAF la CAF il y a
une femme qui est venue chez nous et il
a dit voilà on va vous faire et les 60
000 €, je l'ai pas pris on a moi ou non
c'est des années et des années qui et ça
c'est notre droit et on se défend il y a
un truc au tribunal j'ai pas répondu il
y a un truc au tribunal et on attend
l'audience moi si j'étais fraudeur comme
ils disent je vais pas aller au tribunal
je vais pas attaquer j'ai il y a une
audio ce tribunal il y a un avocat il y
a à la recherche jamais on n'a jamais
fraudé jamais jamais et si je vous vois
personnellement je vous explique plein
de détails bah expliquez-moi non je vais
faire ça parce que c'est on va il nous
faut de il faut qu'on finit demain matin
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez
dire à l'américaine il nous regarde
américain on aura leur avocat euh voilà
qui va nous parler demain ou par
téléphone ou tout ce que vous devez
l'appeler là mais c'est on va être un
petit peu court à mettre Del Rio
qu'est-ce que vous leur diriez ben moi
je voudrais dire à Monsieur monsieur le
maire de Cannes que et moi je suis un
citoyen de Cannes ça fait moi j'ai ça
fait 35 ans que je suis à Cannes ma
femme il est né à Cannes ce petit il a
fait les réparable et les et
[Musique]
que le meilleur vous a donné rendez-vous
ce jour le père de l'agresseur a refusé
ah non c'est pas vrai
monsieur monsieur dame j'étais devant la
mairie à 6h du matin pour ne pas le
louper pour que je le vois pour que je
lui parle parce que chaque fois que je
passe son adjoint et les il me il me
pointe jusqu'à ce qu'il passe les deux
mois dans lequel je peux attaquer au
tribunal et d'ailleurs les deux mois ils
se sont passés ils m'ont donné un
rendez-vous après deux mois j'ai écrit à
la lettre donne-moi des après quand je
suis venu me dire non non attendez
jusqu'à au jugement comme c'est eux ils
sont responsables jugement c'est pas
grave et la dernière fois je me suis
pointé à 6h du matin jusqu'à 14h je suis
un homme j'ai 56 ans j'ai du mal de dos
dans le froid et les passer le chef de
la police municipale il m'a elle m'a
peur harcelé je lui ai dit non je suis
devant chez moi je suis dans ma ville
bref et il est descendu le même adjoint
de maire et m'a dit monté une chaise
arrive gênant je vais pas monter
monsieur Monsieur
l'Adjoint je vais pas dire son nom parce
que chaque fois il me parle je veux voir
Monsieur le Maire et je suis resté
jusqu'à 14h et une éternité rien il m'a
pas reçu et aujourd'hui parce que j'ai
pris un avocat et quand j'ai parlé avec
la presse c'est moi que je m'y attise
alors lui c'est sur mon nom mon nom de
famille de 5 filles
ils disent également l'américaine que
pour la CAF vous Bouchez vous avez
demandé un conseiller départemental
d'intervenir en votre faveur donc c'est
bien connu
l'affaire est connue de l'affaire de la
CAF que vous avez demandé apparemment à
un conseiller départemental d'intervenir
en votre faveur
cette procédure est devant le tribunal
administrative pour l'instant on n'a pas
de décision qui a été rendue puis bon
comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure
excusez-moi comment comment a-t-il eu
cette information et j'ai pas vu le
maire de Cannes c'est mouvoir sur la
question des données publiques lorsque
le parquet national financier a ouvert
une enquête à l'encontre d'Éric sotti
sur une question justement de travail
dissimulé qui reprochait à son épouse
je comprends pas je comprends votre
désarroi
je dois être à la rue avec mes enfants
et là j'avais dit ça monsieur
venez là c'est que on a pas du tout
envie que vous retrouver dans la rue ça
c'est sûr et je crois que personne ici
forcément
ce que j'aimerais moi aussi c'est que
vraiment que vous voyez tous les deux
parce que vous êtes sûr que ça va très
bien se passer là cet enfant et qu'il
m'aide qu'il voit que je suis qu'est-ce
qu'il a cet enfant il a failli tuer une
vieille dame parce que là que votre
enfant dans sa tête pour qu'il fait ça
bien sûr
téléviseur quelque part les parents
payent le télévisoire
on est en train de
s'il vous plaît merci
parce que moi j'ai des filles comme ça
des enfants et on a des enfants qui sont
à la facultés infirmière il y en a qui
vont passer leur bac tous et même cet
enfant et il a fait des bêtises enfants
de de changer
parce que est-ce que vous voudriez voir
le maire de Cannes là est-ce qu'on peut
essayer de voir si s'il peut me répondre
est-ce qu'il peut essayer de le voir
demain ou après-demain pour régler pour
voilà bon moment que vous voyez parce
que vous avez parlé que vous avez refusé
le rendez-vous est-ce que vous êtes
prêts à le voir demain j'ai au moins je
suis vous êtes prévoir demain je suis
prêt à le revoir demain mais
de ma place qui me laisse travailler
avec lui est-ce que vous êtes prêts voir
mais c'est ma place pourquoi
non non attendez on va parler de ça
aussi je fais pas des conditions merde
mais je veux pas non plus aller la
troisième fois il a quatre fois moi il
me tourner après
je le refuse pas je le refuse pas le
rendez-vous non mais est-ce que vous
refusez rien
refusez pas ok
on espère que ça va se faire je pense
que le maire de vous voir aussi comme ça
au moins vous en parler le maire de
Cannes il a pas envie de vous retrouver
à la rue aussi je vous le dis voilà il a
peur
excusez-moi et oui il dit qu'il va tout
mettre en oeuvre pour procéder à
l'expulsion de cette famille donc bon
c'est ce que je veux comme sur le maire
de soi je veux que c'est le maire il
veut pas que je sois dans la rue il veut
pas qu'il pense
et qu'il me laisse cette place dans
laquelle je travaille depuis il a été
choqué comme tout le monde par dessus
le plus choqué en France c'est moi merci
le plus le plus
juste merci ce qui m'a fait ça et c'est
dans moi j'ai crié pour qu'il lui arrive
rien moi j'étais mal j'ai j'avais une
réponse de la mairie très vite merci en
tout cas merci c'est vrai que voilà nous
on a envie personne soit la rue shaib
aussi ça nous font le cœur aussi voilà
et ces autres enfants on a eu sa fille
et forcément je vous dis même le maire
de Cannes il a il a un cœur a lui aussi
je pense qu'il voilà ça fait chier mais
il a parlé avec en comme un fils avec sa
maman il a été très choqué par les
images comme beaucoup de monde